it is so good to see you thank you for
coming in our et Canada studio thank you
so much I use nothing low-key about it
yes I love that this song is incredible
I heard it once and usually takes me
three or four times to be like to decide
if I like a song but immediately the
hook got me wow that's so crazy
where did you find the song what's the
story behind it
tell me more well it's pretty awesome so
Charles Chavez who's who's on my team
yep he basically found the record so he
was in a meeting and one of the I think
was a publisher played him the song and
he was like oh my gosh wait what is that
when you hear it again is anybody on it
like you know what's the deal and end up
being available and I he called me and
he was so excited he was like ally like
this is I just heard this record it's
something so special
the most you know amazing writers and
producers are a part of it like oh my
gosh I feel like this is the one for you
and I'm like wow okay and the crazy
thing is - I had another song that we
picked out as my single right so it was
like whoa and then I heard it the next
day in his car and it was like oh my
gosh I knew it like that was the one
that's crazy
great yeah but when you know you just
know deep in your heart that that's for
you that's the thing and like I had
worked so hard in the studio over the
past few months trying to find my sound
voice my voice
the songs who was Ally gonna be how is
she gonna represent herself and that's
hard you know especially coming out of a
group you know and I just wanted it to
be organically me and you know it took
longer than I expected but it's okay
that's okay with the way thank you so
much that's why I felt like I just felt
my heart like this is it's perfect you
know and I don't know something like
that exactly that's the most important
thing I didn't want to just rush because
of a time frame or anything no I wanted
to make sure that the song right right
and tigers on it yeah it's super
and hot in the video all right tell me
about that how did he jump on board and
what was the chemistry like on set it
looked pretty darn good I think you look
very good thank you so much
so basically the song didn't have like a
space for a feature yeah so I didn't
think oh let me put a rapper and put you
know someone the record let me go search
no the label was actually like hey we
feel like we can add a rapper to this
great way to go for Tyga and I'm like
whoa that would be insane like I I hope
he does it I want to get his thoughts
you know you never know and then he
ended up being on it and I heard it on
my phone and I went crazy I was like man
this is crazy this is my record and he
also give me a shout-out which is cool
he says throw me the alley I'm a Duncan
way in there I was like great this is
right that's awesome
yeah so so he was all in it wasn't just
like he threw he threw the recorded the
track and disappeared like he woman he
was all just trying to show to the video
like here's the best yeah cuz you know
with some features it's just like a you
know quick I'm gonna throw this and then
by but he he was on video and he was so
cool like we we met on set and it was
just instantly I like I felt like I knew
him and our conversations are so easy we
talked about music we talked about were
each other's rum like and he told me he
was like yo and they sent me the record
like I was like oh yeah like this is it
ah I was like that's dope thank you
thank you so much it's so cool and we're
you know we're friends and we'll text
each other every now and then and
support whatever each other is doing and
I really appreciate that you know
somewhat you know as talented as him at
his level
yeah is nice back and actually genuinely
supports me you know I think it's cool
talk a little bit about the album you
know it like you said it took some time
for you to find which one worked best
for you and the songs exactly what's the
theme what's the vibe tell me a little
bit about it well Loki's definitely an
indication of what's to come
I already have some records that I'm
like no these are gonna be on the album
I can't wait I already have ideas for
them can't wait for my fans to hear
the vibe is gonna be hmm and that gave
me too much away yeah there's definitely
gonna be some sultry still those like
pop urban vibes you know so that your
voice my single suited let's change but
you better like it thank those students
with that yeah and and there'll be some
other fun flavors as well sweet and
maybe some cool collabs so we'll see
excellent
yeah that's amazing and it's not coming
anytime soon but the shrine frame is
hopefully in the fall that's great and I
love fall so I mean hopefully that'll
work perfect and then that's when you'll
come back here again yeah and then we'll
go through the whole thing yeah that's
what we'll do man I'm so excited so talk
about I mean listen getting to this
point has been a journey and you know
you talk about finding your own voice
and finding your confidence and all of
that how was that journey for you
because I think a lot of women can learn
from that
yes so being in a group you know it was
it was great yeah had its ups and downs
sure and I think for me I struggled a
lot with just finding finding who I was
and I for a long time I just I don't
know I just didn't really feel like I
was um who I was meant to be are really
shown what I was capable of and for
years that was really hard to kind of
deal with you know you have this amazing
success and all this but I don't feel
fully you know lied you feel trapped in
it a little bit because you weren't you
I'm not trapped but like I think we all
kind of felt like it was a great and
everything but at some point you know oh
we you know it's not the exact music or
the exact image and all that you know
and I think that's okay like I think as
people change and grow whether whatever
business you're in yeah are there
reasons and seasons for each piece that
led you to here
exactly and I'm just gonna say we oh we
all auditioned as solo artists yeah so
you know we all kind of have that but I
did like I really went hard for the
group and I was like the frickin like I
really wanted everything good to happen
to it and we had our time and now I'm in
my solo journey and
this past year has been really
incredible for me because I've really
gotten back to Who I am I've reconnected
with some old friends I've I've I've
gained even deeper relationships with my
family and experienced some remarkable
things with them and obviously you know
found my sound and found the music and
it's amazing you know the song came out
on January 31st it was the perfect way
to start you know fresh a whole new year
you know and just kind of embark on this
next story in chapter of my life so for
a long time again like I really
struggled with I feel like it was
emotional for you like it was yeah it
was and you know I'm really happy now
that I'm surrounded by an amazing team
who loves me love me as a person and
they believe in me wholeheartedly and
they're there for me through the ups and
downs took a while a while to find us
you